when I
sleep I see strange
things
memories not
Memories new
things I see
everything that is
not
[Music]
everything
what a wonderful
day
[Music]
forign
spee
[Music]
fore
in three two
[Music]
action so good good good good sh
thead anyone but him I didn't approve
him you know that you are literally the
last person on Earth I want to see slap
the out of you I really could and
open to that in a safer
environment you been a ghost no phone
call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so have if you
been God I hate that thumbs up stunky
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunt guy
we need to keep it profes profess is my
middle name you said your middle name
was Danger
you how do we do
boss really yeah holster that it's
Holsted it's done forget you you never
saw
it Tom
Ryder the biggest action star on the
planet is missing you need to bring him
back oh J's movie is dead why me you're
a stump man nobody's going to notice you
that's your job no offense I mean some
taking you find rer save Jody's film you
get the love of your life back I'm not
the hero I'm just the double not today
you're
not Tom we already need you back on set
[Music]
pal dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail
he was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I had no choice I had to do some
Jason board
they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you can make it
you can make it you can't make it it's
too dangerous got to be stairs okay okay
what happened to your face you look
terrible you look
amazing you fall down you get right back
up how far would you go for the one that
you
love I'll BL you drink when this is over
engage your
core
boy what are you doing later want to go
to a beach somewhere drink a spicy
Margarita make some bad decisions
yes the and to
[Applause]
blame
mahito
so you made it
mother have a
seat it's this way
mahito a lot of strange things happen in
this place pleas Jo us I just hope he
stays
safe save me save me myo what exactly
are
you your mother she's awaiting your
rescue I'll be your
guide what is this
place this world is filled with the
dead I know it's a lie but I have to
see I'm looking for
someone let's
go we must protect this world ourselves
go back now go
I you and I aren't friends or Allies
kid don't let go no matter what
[Music]
ready you see this
world there's more work to be
[Music]
done a gray Heron once told me that all
gray hair arons are liars so is that the
truth or a lie a lie
truth we have to be a lie
[Music]
too why are you here
R I lost my
job the baby's going to be here pretty
soon no
respect what do you do with the those
feelings you know you could be a part of
our
family I know some guys they like to
help out guys like us what they're like
buddies
ears the doctor wants me to get a bunch
of tests test are so expensive do you
still want to go through with
it other guys like they live with you
just like regular families except
regular folks don't get to choose their
family we do how would that work depends
on
you why do we make ourselves so much
smaller than we
are
pain that holds us back take back your
power
Ralph welcome Ralph son manad
Drome what if I'm just
broken you have to raise an army inside
yourself baby you really got to tell me
what's going on
here watch out for yourself
okay
starts I'm to tell the world there is no
God but
Ralph what you decide will be the only
thing there
[Music]
is I worry that we're all kind of
disconnected did you ask me something
huh what this way okay good
C do you think it's good for you to live
like this head up you're really not
supposed to use your hands quiet family
meeting downstairs let's go can you help
me with this problem I'm kidding you
can't help me no I can't we are going to
make a happy memory as a
family I wish you could be me I would
love for you to be me for one day I
would love for you to know what it's
like to be I would kill to eat a dozen
donuts and just have it burn right off
would you take a picture of my family
please everybody say merry
[Music]
Christmas what are you doing in my bed
you're in my bed why am I in your bed
[Music]
Mar what is happening that's me see here
Mom
W
there
this is a situation that has never
happened before I'm 17 again I'm 13
Going on 30 so freaky what's wrong with
Pickles what's going on with Miles
pickles is Miles what's My Age Again we
just need to get through today and
figure out how this happened your dad
happens to be the toast and high
school's got in my JY you stole my first
kiss no I pulled away you rejected
Ariana Dad I can't believe I thought we
could pull this off be a boss be a boss
uhhuh be a boss be a
boss what's My Age
Again sounds like you need to fix what
is broken we've got this our Walkers and
Walkers never quit
GS I think I T
A more than anything I just want you to
be okay we have 24 hours we don't figure
this out we're going to be stuck like
this forever this the most exciting
thing I've done in years whatever
happens we'll get through it together
this is just a dream and we have to wake
up
claing
[Music]
W I think the dog and the baby are
spending too much time together what's
My Age
[Music]
Again Bernie hey how you doing man very
badly
i' missed my daughter's birthday I'm
going to take Eve to my mom's my wife
left me and then I got fired I want you
out today that's when I happened to on
this old antique jewelry box and then I
rubbed
it God who are you I am a genie yeah go
your wish is my command okay I wish I
had my very own camel
if you're an actual Genie explain the
whole three wishes things fairy tale
stuff real genie unlimited
wishes I wish I had large pizza
pepperoni extra
cheese this is just a triangle of Red
Bread go and try
it wait an ever loving minute this is
heaven it's the most
this place is Big you've obviously been
inside that Bo slightly longer than you
think how long are we talking about look
what I found 2,000 years what do you
call it oh sanitizer
sanitizer M
zesty I need to get my wife and kids to
love me again and for us to be happy
start was kind sprucing up the
place uh go make it the Mona
Lisa I mean she could have smiled right
it's the was Wonder Years from now I
want you to remember be the very best
friend that they ever
had you're going to love
[Music]
this so tell me about this whole
Christmas thing of yours it was meant to
celebrate the birth of Jesus Christ
Jesus are you talking about Mary's kid
you actually met him what did he do to
get so famous we turn out to be Son of
God oh no I thought he was
[Music]
kidding excuse
me hey oh my God oh my God we're not a
threat don't don't look at us like that
sorry I'm yeah
no excuse
me you sure you're in the right place
feel certain I've never seen you at one
of these Affairs
before little B Peep has lost her
way I don't think she'd be scared I
think she's really braver than you
think the election was a prescripted
puppet show just like every
[Music]
year you two are a complete pair of
cosmopolit snobs you know that
[Music]
yeah I need to know what's going on down
in that basement
now what in your young life could you
have encountered to inspire you I don't
know I never really cared about that
stuff glad they figured out how to make
movies like less boring than this did
[Music]
they
my&
morning no I I do know that I just I
don't like being like told things about
[Music]
myself
[Applause]
no no wait I don't have your number oh I
don't have a cell
[Laughter]
phone just do it fast please do it fast
my God it's not going
through I'm just kidding you literally
haven't even gone in
yet oh my
God oh my God oh my God is hurting you
I'm so sorry yo this is my
Jam what up what up wait what you don't
know who I am you
ready keep likes you I don't think so
anyway he's popular you're popular SP
what are you going to do when we're done
with
[Music]
school guess go do more
school what about
you um
prostitution is with you in that I don't
know I just want to
leave you
will ry's mom walks in the
basement No 2 3 all
[Music]
right where were
you I had Bible study today with Leah no
you didn't so where the were you I
don't know what you're talking about was
lettuce your little girlfriend been
going through a lot lately you can tell
me
sometimes I just want to leave this
whole place behind and forget it and
everyone in it want to see his make out
this all will be over soon are you a
virgin at least that's what I keep
telling myself you know you're so pretty
so are
you what if I have know where to go
after this everyone has somewhere to go
no I let up for a whole month I don't
will if you really want to not everyone
is going to like you but some people
might
[Music]
right that is not going to fit know Jew
through I need to stretch
it it's been a year that dog just given
up on
him it only takes one memory one memory
to get him
started you be okay just you and
him you be okay just you
and
Alex
1937 Kelvin
too what
[Applause]
the the self-portrait you found it what
can you tell me about Calvin why do you
ask I mean they're exactly the
same he was a genius
this world and
beyond my mind's playing tricks on me
you're out there all by yourself I'm not
here by
myself you've seen them haven't
you seen who
Calvin he liked to hurt
women hey
he loves his wounded
Birds
loves Alex he'll be
back that's a thing about our
family we always remember
back
Professor Lewis yes and ah nice to meet
you and you good
luck Dr frud sit please not there that's
the transformation couch you be
careful why would you come here to see
me if you disagree so passionately with
My Views you've insisted all your lives
to the the very concept of God is
ludicrous yes clash between God and
Satan ah but I did not say whose side I
was on I consider what people tell me
far less interesting than what they
choose not to tell me have you
frightened off your professor yet not
yet soon
perhaps you challenge my disbelief is
that great I do well done God too late
to turn back
now it seems to me Professor you've
never matured enough to face the teror
of being alone in the
dark what is it you think I'm yeah we're
all
terrified do you bury your doubts you
bury your members of the war but at the
core of your
being we're all cowards before
death
[Music]
Davey I don't remember mommy being
pregnant with you I don't remember
seeing any pictures of her pregnant
either so now you think I'm adopted you
brought me an airplane to Ambush me with
this I just thought that maybe in Bonos
ciris we could try and find
out hi Mommy Diana dear we're save you
sleeping just keep an eye on him
don't worry this is really good for him
now that we're here don't you feel
something
whatever maybe you like to see some
authentic Tango It's Not For
[Applause]
[Music]
Tourists I want to dance with men
Argentinian men so much the
bo do you think Tango is oldfashioned
sexist yeah but in a good way Taps into
something
Primal take off your juice you can't
petin those how do you like whenis are
you stay long just a few weeks our
parents are from here actually when did
your family move away I think it was
like the early 80s we were both really
little when we left the early ' 80s was
a difficult time here a lot of people
left to escape do you have your birth
certificate yeah I have it it has both
their parents' names on it sometimes the
birth certificate contains false
information my whole life I felt like an
outsider in this
family and it's time to leave all this
where it belongs the past I know I
started this da I know I did I just
never imagined that it would my misery
is the only meaningful thing in your
life
[Music]
life hello you have the result of your
DNA test we know the reason they left
here why didn't they want us to
[Music]
come
for
[Music]
[Applause]
foree
[Music]
for
foree
[Music]
Phil LED an era of bodybuilding that we
may never see
again in the world of
bodybuilding this would be the biggest
comeback of all my name is Philip gerro
Heath I'm a seven time Mr Olympia and
I'm going after number eight the Mr
Olympia is and whatever will be the
greatest bodybuilding show on the planet
Arnold szer was Mr Olympia Jay Cutler
Ronnie Coleman it's Last Man Standing
just like Jordan just like Ali just like
some guy known as The Rock who used to
raise his
eyebrow I judge you shoulders arms chest
the legs it's nothing but condition
shape and
size it's extremely competitive we
didn't have a rivalry we just despise
one another he's going to do something
nuts I was so excited to go give them
hell it was such an extreme level it
finally came to the point where it hurt
his physique as I'm s in my belt I feel
like a pop and I'm like oh my God oh my
God oh my
God he knew that this could be the end
of his
career I wanted to kill myself at that
point
I thought that Phil was
done but I thought if I made a
comeback what would that look
[Music]
like he focuses himself to one of the
hardest sports in the
world I ain't dead I ain't dying I'm
good I'm still standing I still have the
fire
it's do or
di it's
War it's the Mr Olympia or
nothing let the games
[Applause]
[Music]
begin